(upbeat mariachi music)
- Don't you think this apple looks cute
and ripe and young?
^ Just kidding!
^ This apple is old as hell.
^ Due to a little something called
^ controlled atmosphere storage
^ apples can take a long time to ripen.
^ Which means this baby apple
^ could actually be over a year old.
Here's the thing about cherries.
^ Sometimes after a heavy rain
^ little cherries can split open.
^ So cherry farmers will send big old helicopters
^ to fly over their crop to air dry them
^ so they don't freak out and break apart.
^ Take about (beep) divas.
^ Am I right?
Fun little fact about oranges.
^ They're not always orange.
^ Sometimes they're green.
^ In places where it's hot all the time
^ oranges will stay green
^ because they only turn orange
^ after the weather gets cool.
Might be safe to assume that strawberries
are berries, right?
(buzzer)
Wrong!
^ Strawberries are actually something
^ called accessory fruits which means
^ they were developed in areas outside
^ of the fruit's ovaries.
I didn't even know fruits had ovaries.
Watch out!
^ Grapefruits can interract with certain medications
^ in ways that can be really harmful to your body.
It's so scary!
But it's so cute.
Do you love bananas?
Because I love bananas.
^ But sadly they might be extinct in the future
^ due to a little disease called tropical race 4.
I could go for a nice little handsome banan.
What's up baby?
How you doing?
(upbeat mariachi music)